welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn woke your host and our guest is
Susan hide assistant professor of
political science and international
studies at yale university professor
hides research interests include
international influences on domestic
politics elections in developing
countries international norm creation
and the use of natural and field
experimental research methods her
current research explores the effects of
international democracy promotion
efforts with a particular focus on
international election observation she
is served as an international observer
with a Carter Center and the
Organization for Security and
Cooperation in Europe for elections in
Albania Indonesia Nicaragua and
Venezuela and has also worked for the
democracy program at the Carter Center
today we'll be talking with her about
her newest endeavor the pseudo Democrats
dilemma why election monitoring became
an international norm welcome professor
Hyde thanks for having me tell us about
the premise of your book so when
describing the project I like to
describe the puzzle that I began with
and that is that I noticed that a number
of leaders throughout the world were
inviting international election monitors
and then committing large-scale election
fraud in front of them and so the book
was motivated by my interested in that
phenomenon and trying to explain it but
really what the book has become about is
why election monitoring became an
international norm okay the term pseudo
Democrat mom is that something you kind
and what actually is it I I don't think
I don't think I can claim making up the
term there's a lot of ways in which
leaders in the developing world are
described but I use it in the sense that
pseudo Democrats are leaders who are
willing to hold elections their
governments are willing to hold
elections maybe even willing to hold
democratic
but what they're not willing to do is
lose and peacefully transfer power to to
another party so they're the types of
governments throughout the world that
engage in an election manipulation
sometimes they engage in what I call
strategic manipulation which they're
trying to steal the elections but not
get caught okay and they're very
interesting leaders to study I would say
there are lots of good stories about
them okay one of the contributions of
your book is your theory of
international norm creation tell us
about it okay so it again was developed
to explain election monitoring but I now
think that it applies to other types of
international norms I think one way to
look at international politics is to
divide the world into states that are
viewed as good types of states and
states they're viewed as bad types of
states and my theory basically looks at
what happens when the preferences of
powerful states change in regard to what
types of states they prefer to work with
and so in the 1960s and then really at
the end of the Cold War in the late
1980s many powerful states began
promoting democracy with with and
expressing their preference to work with
other democratic states states
throughout the developing world
responded to this by inviting election
monitors I think they could have done a
lot of other things but they happen to
start doing this and these were these
were governments who were actually
democratizing they were looking for a
way to signal their type that they were
one of the good governments committed to
democracy to international audiences and
it became a perception that all good
types invited election monitors which
meant that if if you weren't inviting
international election monitors you must
be a bad type which which is why I think
that the behavior of inviting
international lecture monitor spread to
even those governments that are holding
fraudulent elections okay so it's kind
of it's pretty dynamic yeah so let's
talk some specific about the the
countries that you have observed so my
project focus is on the global diffusion
of election monitoring so it's
throughout the entire world
but I personally have the had the
opportunity to travel to 25 different
countries to serve as an election
monitor with three different groups and
so the first one first place I went was
Venezuela and during the recall
referendum for the Chavez and the most
recent place that I went to is Pakistan
for the 2008 elections there well that
must have been fascinating talk a little
bit in some highlights of what that was
like well that particular case was
interesting in part because the security
situation was somewhat tenuous so we
weren't really allowed to observe in a
lot of the places that I think many
people in the delegation would have
liked to have gone to but it one of the
remarkable things about the election is
that despite all the complaints and the
pre-election violence and the complaints
that many of the parties had about the
preparations for the election the
opposition actually one and this
surprised everyone at the time and it
raises a lot of questions about you know
how much do is this election
manipulation or election violence matter
if the opposition party is able to win
anyway okay let's talk a little bit
about the methodology you used in the
book how did you gather the data so I
like to call my approach as do many
people in political science right now a
multi-method approach so I have the
picture of election monitoring since it
was first initiated in sovereign states
in the early 1960s until the present but
I also use a variety of other methods
including field experimental methods and
there's a natural experiment as well and
so what that means I guess I should back
up a little bit and just say rather than
talking just about the methods one of
the important parts of my theory is that
election monitoring has to be costly to
the government's that invite election
monitors and try to steal the elections
if it doesn't matter to them then my
whole thing falls apart and it doesn't
work very well so very early on and
became interested in figuring out how
you could prove that election monitors
matter to governments are cheating and
the way that I sort of stumbled upon was
to look at micro level variation in the
performance of the cheating candidates
relative to whether international
observers were there monitoring the
polling stations or not and so the first
case was that I looked at in this way
was actually a natural experiment and
what that means is that the in this case
is that the assignment of observers to
polling stations was close to random so
everything else can be virtually held
constant and you can just compare the
group of polling station so it's
monitored with those that weren't and in
this case the incumbent did six percent
worse in the monitored polling stations
that an unmonitored polling stations
implying that he got six percent less or
fewer votes than he otherwise would have
gotten had he been allowed to or had he
not been internationally monitored in
those polling stations okay and what are
you doing when you're when you're
actually observing know is that entail
yeah so it's I think it's maybe less
interesting than it sounds at first but
there's there's a variety of types of
election monitoring but what i have done
primarily a short-term election
monitoring which is mostly around
election day and then i come in with a
bunch of other people a few days before
the election and become it a sort of
crash course and the procedures that are
supposed to be happening in that
election in that particular country in
that particular day problems that have
already happened issues to be looking
out for that sort of things so a very
intensive training period then you're
given your assignment and deployed
somewhere in the country so they try to
deploy election monitors throughout
throughout the country that that's being
observed and then during the day before
election that you meet with a lot of
party officials and election officials
police whoever is in the community that
that might have a stake in the election
see me with them the day before on
Election Day you basically just go from
polling station to point station with
the clipboard ask talking to people
filling out a questionnaire that's you
know specific to that country are the
procedures that are supposed to be
taking place actually taking place and
then
you calling your findings periodically
if there's any major problems you're
supposed to stay longer and document it
you spend a lot of time talking to
voters see if anything unusual has
happened to them trying again to
document things that are reported to you
and then usually you end up watching the
counting of the votes which can be
sometimes interesting sometimes quite
long and boring of a process and then
you sometimes will follow the the
ballots through another stage of
aggregation so they're carried up to
another level and you again watch the
tabulation process there have you been
in any countries have you observed any
elections where there has been fraud and
how can you how do you tell the fraud
has been committed oh I haven't seen
very much overt fraud with my own eyes a
lot of election monitor reports most of
them don't say this election was
fraudulent the selection was free and
fair they're much more nuanced and so
for example in Albania I didn't see a
woman cast her own ballad until well
after noon and that was because they
have a common practice they're a family
voting where the head of the household
who's always a man stands in the polling
place and cast about for every member of
this extended family is okay I mean it's
it's a traditional practice and but it's
not consistent with having a secret
ballot when the democratic election in
that sense so it wasn't a very big deal
i mean the election overall was it was
otherwise pretty good but this is a
practice that the people were quite
concerned with Venezuela things are very
tense there you spend a lot of time
getting yelled at as an international
observer in Lyonesse whele by both sides
equally but you know again you see
things that are you hear a lot more
complaints than you actually see so you
know so-and-so says that they tried to
vote and they were told that they're
actually deceased and so and so there's
a lot of a million stories like that
embedder that are harder to document
okay in your book you reach certain
conclusions talk about some of them
well one of my main conclusions I guess
a more general conclusion is that is
related to democracy promotion so a lot
of the talk about democracy promotion is
is very critical and that democracy
promotion is inconsistent for example US
democracy promotion we continue to
support dictatorship so therefore
democracy promotion policy must be
hypocritical or something like that and
what my project highlights is that that
even when other interests are at stake
for governments promoting democracy that
some some support for for democracy can
have some unintended effects and give
governments the incentive to try to at
least act like democracies if not
actually become become democratic it
also in terms of international
monitoring so this has come up recently
in relation to weapons inspection right
so the types of governments that are
there's two different states of the
world one in which if you refuse to
allow inspectors in for weapons
inspection or for international election
monitors you're assuming to be guilty
because we expect that governments have
nothing to hide will let in let in
monitors and I think an interesting part
of an implication of my book is that the
reason why election monitoring was
allowed to get to that state in which if
you don't invite election monitors your
assumed to be doing something bad was in
part because election monitoring isn't
perfect so the pseudo Democrats could
potentially fool international observers
and get a positive report for their
elections had that not happened had that
not been possible had a lecture
monitoring been perfect from the
beginning my opinion and is harder to
prove but my opinion is that that the
state leaders who are committing
election fraud just would have said we
are a sovereign state we refuse to
invite election monitors there would
have been nothing in it for them to
invite external scrutiny and I think the
same dynamic applies across a lot of
issue areas in which there is some type
of monitoring or enforcement regime okay
final question what was the most
surprising thing for
in researching and writing the book I
think I think it's the most surprising
thing but definitely one of the more fun
things is all of the methods that
governments use to steal elections so
I've had a good time just documenting
all of the the ways in which they've
been caught trying to steal elections
usually what I can find out about our
the government's are bad as stealing
elections because they're the ones who
get caught I think there's probably a
number of governments out there who are
who are actually good at concealing
election manipulation and therefore
don't get caught but I guess the other
surprise inside of this is that in that
political scientists tend to assume
assume away and they don't look at it as
an interesting question is that it's
actually quite hard to steal an election
and it's even harder to steal an
election and not get caught so there's a
lot of ways in which that can go wrong
and we've seen that we see this over and
over again so the again to bring up the
Iranians the most recent Iranian
election I think was a really
interesting case of this in which by the
end of the election day people were
pretty sure that something had gone
wrong although I think the government
came could pretty close to being able to
get away with with election manipulation
okay very entertaining thank you very
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your research thank you
for having me for more information about
professor hide in her work please visit
our website at Yale dat edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at ya
you